nick cage sonic's triumphant return and
a gay take on jane austen it's been a
crazy year for comedy
you have probably already heard of one
of the most talked about movies of the
year everything everywhere all at once
this is a movie that defies definition
by dipping its hot dog shaped fingers
into several different genres such as
action adventure drama sci-fi martial
arts and many more one of the constants
throughout the mind-bending experience
of watching this film is just how funny
it is but that doesn't mean you won't
need some help understanding the ending
everything everywhere all at once is an
absurd remedy about a chinese american
immigrant named evelyn who is thrust
into a maddening multiversal story
revolving around her family this is one
of those movies that manages to balance
the bonkers randomness of its humor with
the grounded and realistic portrayals of
its characters to amazing effect
thanks in no small part to the
performances of his main cast upon
release a movie was met with universal
acclaim and praised for its creative
premise powerful performances and
genuinely hilarious comedy it has gone
on to be described by many as one of the
best films ever made and it really can
only be seen to be believed
on the complete opposite end of the
comedy spectrum is jackass forever a
movie that has no pretensions of
grandeur the jackass franchise has
existed for over two decades simply by
giving us hilarious movies of funny guys
and gals hurting themselves on camera
sometimes that's all you need and
considering that one of the stunts in
this movie involving a bull nearly
killed star johnny knoxville these guys
literally put their blood sweat and
tears into making it jackass forever is
the fourth mainline film in the series
and like the others it focuses on
putting its stars in dangerously
compromising situations to extreme
stunts pranks and general tomfoolery
this latest installment features almost
all the same cast members from previous
films and also aims to pass the torch of
self-endangerment to a new generation of
daredevils with even more onset injuries
than ever there's a reason that jackass
forever has become the most highly rated
film in the franchise
it should come as no surprise to film
buffs out there that a pixar movie ended
up on this list pixar films tend to
strike a balance between humorous and
heartwarming while wrapped in a high
concept package and turning red is no
exception this film features an
incredible cast and ambitious script
that has sparked some unfortunate
internet drama turning red is one of the
latest films from pixar studios telling
the story of may lee a 13 year old
chinese canadian girl who magically gets
turned into a giant red panda during
moments of intense emotion the film
portrays this transformation as both
serious and comedic with it being a
condition passed down through a family
that is meant to be controlled once may
and her friends realize the unique
potential of using the panda to their
advantage they fully embrace using it
for money making clouds to hilarious
results i'm paying for the red panda not
this garbage as a classic coming of age
tale about a teenage girl going through
major changes the story walks a line
between goofy jokes and more serious
family drama to create a film that many
regard as one of pixar's best in years
one of the more strange and humorously
named movies on this list is the
unbearable weight of massive talent
which stars and is entirely focused on
nick cage who plays a version of himself
the film is an action comedy that
follows the escapades of cage as he
deals with a struggling film career as
well as family issues all these things
are more come to a head as a famed actor
gets himself involved in a massive plot
beyond his control as a self-indulgent
but undeniably charming film the
unbearable weight of massive talent
shows a nick cage whose career is
struggling amid numerous bugs-office
flops and who is taunted by visions of
his past self out of desperation cage is
brought to spain to meet with a wealthy
fanboy from there the plot goes off the
rails involving drug trafficking
kidnapping and the cia by being
appropriately tongue-in-cheek this movie
has been regarded by many as one of
cage's best roles in decades while also
managing to be a genuinely hilarious
comedy at the same time could this be
the start of a nick cage renaissance
that that remains to be seen
as one of the most anticipated animated
comedies of the year it should come as
no surprise to fans that the bob's
burgers movie lived up to the
expectations based on the award-winning
fox series of the same name this movie
took everything fun about bob's burgers
and turned it up for the big screen
bob's burgers is about the belcher
family with bob linda tina jean and
louise all dealing with the difficulties
of running a burger business the show
has gone on for 12 seasons since 2011
and has gained a massive cult following
for its wacky humor puns musical numbers
and endearing characters it was only a
matter of time before bob's burgers got
a feature film of its own the bob's
burgers movie focuses on the belchers
suffering financial woes after being
denied an extension on their business
loan as well as having a massive
sinkhole form right in front of their
restaurant upon release critics have
agreed that the bob's burgers movie has
a successful mixture of laugh out loud
silliness or maintaining a satisfyingly
heartfelt story
when people think of not terrible video
game movies one of the few that comes to
mind is probably sonic the hedgehog the
first film was released in 2020 with
audiences everywhere being pleasantly
surprised by the portrayal of sonic and
jim carrey's over-the-top performance as
a villainous dr robotnik it is because
of that success that paramount's
pictures continued the gravy train with
this year's sonic the hedgehog 2. hello
hedgehog
did you miss me
picking up where the first film left off
sonic the hedgehog 2 begins almost 8
months later as dr robotnik seeks
revenge against sonic with the help of
knuckles the echidna sonic recruits the
help of his friends miles tales prower
to find the master emerald before his
enemies do and save the universe as we
know it this may sound like heavy
subject matter but sonic the hedgehog 2
manages to be a light-hearted cartoonish
adventure with lots of slapstick humor
and tongue-in-cheek jokes along the way
with a stacked cast of acting talent it
is no surprise this film gained
significant buzz as being even better
than the first film the man from toronto
is a high octane action comedy film
starring kevin hart woody harrelson and
kaylee cuoco to name a few a man from
toronto has enough laughs and shootouts
to satisfy fans of the genre while also
sporting enjoyable performances from its
lead actors
hart stars as an unsuccessful fitness
instructor who desperately wants to find
success selling his idea of no contact
boxing over the course of the story
teddy is swept into a plot of mistaken
identity when he is confused as being
the man from toronto a highly trained
killer who is actually harrelson's
character together the two go on a globe
trotting adventure while running away
from other assassins and fbi agents as
they navigate this absurd situation
while the film has mostly been panned by
critics and audiences alike there is
still enough comedic gold between hart
and harrelson in the man from toronto to
keep anyone entertained
the recently released chip and dale
rescue rangers implements cgi 2d
animation and live action performances
together in the same movie this film
focuses on chip and dale two cartoon
chipmunks who had a popular real life
show in the 1990s and have since become
losers in the world of chip and dale
rescue rangers animated characters and
humans all live together and interact
with each other like normal this movie
seeks to blend comedy action adventure
mystery and nostalgia into a movie with
lots of jokes that may go over the heads
of younger audiences the story is
centered around the kidnapping of
monterrey jack another character from
the original show and the investigation
chip and dale must undertake to discover
what happened to their friend for many
the main appeal of this movie is a
countless number of cameo appearances by
other characters from animation history
one of the more talked about appearances
is that of ugly sonic voiced by popular
comedian tim robinson as the older
uglier version of cgi sonic from sonic
the hedgehog
another entry in the popular genre of
movies about humans becoming friends
with dogs dog is a road comedy about a
us army ranger with ptsd given the
assignment of taking a military dog to
his friend's funeral across the country
rooted in serious topics like war trauma
family and death is also the comedic
narrative of jackson briggs learning to
develop a relationship with a chaotic
dog that wants to destroy everything in
sight as with most road comedies briggs
and lulu the dog endure several strange
encounters throughout the film that lead
to absolute belly laughs you're just a
demon you're just a demon dog satisfied
audiences and critics alike with
positive reviews and made significant
box office returns on its meager 15
million dollar budget for dog lovers and
channing tatum lovers alike dog is a
film that has a little something for
everyone
the bad guys is an animated comedy
centered around a team of criminal
animals who make a living planning heist
that fit within the reputation of their
species based on a book for children
this film features an impressive cast of
actors in various roles as a team of
criminals known as the bad guys the
animals embrace the negative stereotypes
of their various species by plotting
elaborate heists led by the charming mr
wolf once they accidentally get pictured
doing a good deed during one of their
schemes the team has roped into trying
to reform themselves as good guys in
order to atone for their crimes the bad
guys has filled with witty humor
interesting animation and lots of
exciting action that serves to make this
one of the higher rated animated movies
of the year more than anything many seem
to agree that the film is genuinely
funny for both kids and adults
it's time to talk about the minions with
the recent release of minions the rise
of crew the world has once again been
graced for the big screen presence of
everyone's favorite little yellow banana
loving trouble makers that's the latest
in the despicable me and minions
franchise this film serves as a sequel
to the first standalone minions film
while also simultaneously being a
prequel to the first despicable me
feature illumination entertainment has
managed to create some of the most
iconic animated characters of all time
and the film was a financial smash the
rise of gru takes place in 1975 and
serves to explain how the minions came
to serve the villainous crew who is only
a kid at this time brew and the minions
are roped into a conflict between the
villainous six and their former leader
named wild knuckles as they struggle to
collect the zodiac stone minions a rise
of gru is full of the kind of
minion-based shenanigans that the series
has become known for with lots of
yelling cartoon violence laughing and
banana enjoyment this film also sparked
some real-life comedy when thousands of
moviegoers around the world made it a
meme to see the movie dressed to the
nines in suits calling themselves gentle
minions
fire island is a delightful romantic
comedy about a group of gay men
vacationing on fire island off the coast
of long island while the story is
inspired by pride and prejudice
things get more complicated as the men
navigate romances rivalries judgment and
outrageous circumstances during their
week-long stay and this is why straight
people hate us
the narrative is mainly focused on noah
as he heads to fire island with his
friends as part of a yearly tradition
among the five of them from there noah
has to deal with various flames and
sexual encounters as he and his other
friends tried to have a good time while
understanding this as the last
opportunity they'll get to return to the
island the way they used to throughout
the film are humorous moments of levity
that embrace awkwardness and
misunderstandings fire island has done
considerably well with the critics with
many praising its representation of gay
men and engaging characters